c'est un autre type de guerre que se
livrent les centres commerciaux de la
région chacun y va de sa rénovation
actuellement pour attirer de nouveaux
clients et bien aux clayes-sous-bois le
centre alpha parc assez récent a décidé
de s'étendre alpha parc de a été
inaugurée hier
75 millions d'euros d'investissements
pour réaliser ce centre commercial
tourné vers l'écologie c'est 10 % de
plus que pour une version classique et
15 ans d'amortissement nécessaire avec
le plus grand mur végétal du monde
desjardins et un parking vers
l'extension dafa parcs et aux
clayes-sous-bois mise sur une clientèle
familiale l'immobilier commercial
pendant des années c'était des des
boîtes à chaussures en bardage pourri
qui défiguraient les entrées de ville
nous avons nous décidé
d'investir dans le développement durable
nous avons décidé d'investir dans la
qualité car nous pensons que les clients
à l'époque du commerce électronique vous
continuez à venir dans des centres
commerciaux mais dans lequel ils vont
trouver un plaisir qu'un plaisir de se
promener un plaisir d'aller faire du
loisir une aire de pique nique des
restaurants et des activités de bowling
et de karting sont proposés face à une
concurrence féroce le choix du
développement durable et du loisir s'est
imposé il faut savoir innover en
permanence pour apporter aux clients
basse qu'il souhaite ou ce qu'il ne sait
pas encore qu'il souhaite en fait les
premiers clients étaient attendus
mercredi matin accueillis par des
salariés recrutés le plus souvent
localement au total 700 emplois avec le
labo la première phase d'alpha parcs qui
sont illégaux étaient destinés en
priorité bien sûr où les siens puisque
donc nous avons même organisé des
recrutements à l'intérieur de la ville
tout près d'ici un autre centre
commercial est en train de sortir de
terre positionner sur la houlette de
luxe il devrait permettre la création
d'une centaine d'emplois
et vous l'avez entendu ce mur végétalisé
et le plus grand au monde il est
l'oeuvre de patrick blanc rencontre avec
cet architecte qui n'en est pas à ce
premier à son premier coup d'essai
pardon nous sommes ici aux
clayes-sous-bois devant le mur végétal
le plus grand du monde imaginez-vous
1500 mètres de verdure à côté de moi
patrick blanc alors j'allais dire que
vous étiez le l'architecte paysagiste
mais en fait il n'en est rien vous êtes
botaniste et vous êtes l'auteur de ce
magnifique mur voilà voilà parce que moi
mais mes recherches sur les plantes des
sous bois tropicaux qu'on est bien loin
des sous bois des forêts tropicales on
est donc face à un mur végétal où j'ai
quand même réussi c'est l'avantagé de
botanistes justement à introduire 250
espèces de plantes différentes et en
plus c'est un peu un laboratoire pour
moi puisque comme c'est le plus grand du
monde j'avais sur 250 mètres de longueur
la possibilité justement de tester des
espèces nouvelles que je n'ai jamais
testé avant donc il ya bien sûr des
valeurs sûres les accords us lassé des
valeurs sûres les opéras sont des
valeurs sûres les géraniums aucun
problème à cause de ça il ya d'autres
plantes beaucoup plus osés donc
j'attends avec impatience les mois qui
viennent pour voir l'évolution de ce mur
végétal alors vous connaissez votre
travail notamment au musée du quai
branly là c'est un centre commercial
c'est une nouveauté pour vous ben oui en
france parce que j'ai sévit dans les
centres commerciaux par exemple au
portugal à bangkok plusieurs à plusieurs
reprises mais en france c'est vrai que
c'est c'est nouveau et c'est tout à fait
intéressant parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison pourquoi est ce que dans un
centre commercial on pourrait pas faire
quelque chose qui rende la vie vraiment
agréable et puis que les gens retrouvent
finalement fasse quelque chose
d'exceptionnel puisque il semble bien
que ce soit le plus grand du monde il
semble bien qu'on peut jamais jurer de
ce qui se passe que ce soit mais il
semble bien que ce soit le plus grand en
quelles sont les difficultés justement
pour le mur le plus grand du monde pour
pour orner à de différentes plantes par
un centre commercial pas de difficulté
majeure la halle avantage vous laisser
qui l'orienté sud-sud-ouest donc autant
quand vous êtes dans le sud de la france
ému d'être orienté est ou nord-est où
nord-ouest parce qu'il fait très chaud
autant on doit près de paris c'est bien
mieux d'être orientés sud sud ouest
parce que évidemment ça réchauffe
surtout par une journée froide divers du
coup vous avez un peu de soleil qui
permet même quand il gèle à la glace de
fondre et du coup les plantes peuvent
boire donc pas de difficultés majeures
puisque il est bien exposé l'on est
exposé aux normes ça aurait été plus
difficile mais là je suis très très
content l'exposition donc il devrait
vraiment très bien marcher de façon on
verra très vite là déjà ça pousse et en
même pas deux mois puisque qui a été
planté entre juillet et début août et la
voyez début septembre déjà ça bien
pousser et avant l'hiver là vous verrez
la revenez ans en novembre début
novembre vous verrez que pratiquement
tout le feutre sera couvert et bien on
verra ce moment là merci beaucoup
patrick merci merci au revoir